die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies guten abend und
herzlich willkommen den sport hat heute
norbert lehmann
einen schönen guten abend doch formiert
blicken wir auf die großen themen an
diesem tag
alarmstufe rot warnt der weltklimarat
die erde erwärmt sich deutlich schneller
als angenommen wie reagiert die politik
kampf gegen das feuer auf der
griechischen insel föhr bleibt die lage
dramatisch und ende der olympischen
dienstreise empfang für das deutsche
team im frankfurter römer
[Applaus]
stellen sie sich vor wir haben jetzt
öfter überflutungen wie in nrw und
rheinland pfalz stellen sie sich vor es
gibt regelmäßig hitzewellen wie gerade
in griechenland und im arktischen ozean
verschwinden im sommer die eisschollen
all das sagt der bericht des
weltklimarates der un voraus dafür haben
wissenschaftler innen 14.000
klimastudien durchgeackert das fazit die
folgen der erderwärmung sind
katastrophal an den stern fluten und
flammen hitze und dürre extrem ist die
lage an vielen orten der welt schon
jetzt in diesem sommer noch dramatischer
könnte sie werden in der zukunft denn
die erde heizt sich auf immer schneller
so der bericht bereits in den jahren um
2030 rechnet der weltklimarat mit einem
globalen temperaturanstieg um 1,5 grad
im vergleich zum vorindustriellen
zeitalter 2030 das wäre ein jahrzehnt
früher als bislang angenommen
die folgen lebensgefährliche wetterlagen
öfter und heftiger enorme hitze wählen
könnten alle zehn jahre kommen im
schnitt statt wie bislang etwa alle 50
jahre dazu stärkere stürme und
überschwemmungen
der anstieg des meeresspiegels und das
abschmelzen der eisschollen in der
arktis schon jetzt unumkehrbar heißt es
die wissenschaftler machen klar
all das ist menschengemacht 2009 10 war
laut bericht so viel klimaschädliches
co2 in der atmosphäre wie noch nie in
den vergangenen zwei millionen jahren
jetzt also ist die politik am zug was
folgt aus diesen schlimmen szenarien aus
sicht der eu kommission muss dringend
gehandelt werden entschlossen und alle
zusammen
soviel zur kommissionspräsident
timmermanns wie reagieren die
politischen parteien in deutschland auf
dem bericht des weltklimarates gerade
jetzt im bundestagswahlkampf las
bohnsack berichtet die überschwemmungen
in deutschland haben gezeigt dass der
klimawandel auch bei uns kein
zukunftsthema mehr ist sondern realität
klimaschutz sei eine
überlebensnotwendige aufgabe so die
umweltministerin
die aber noch zu schaffen sein der
weltklimarat sagt erstmal ganz eindeutig
dass diese klimaveränderung menschen
gemacht sind das heißt da keinen zweifel
gibt und das ist sehr wichtig weil das
bedeutet wir können auch gegen steuern
und auch das sagt dieser bericht wenn
die nächsten zehn jahre genutzt werden
um eben treibhausgase zu reduzieren
dann kann man auch die erderwärmung noch
wieder in den griff bekommen in einer
sondersitzung des nordrhein
westfälischen landtags zum hochwasser
spricht der ministerpräsident und
kanzlerkandidat der union von
langjährigen anstrengungen konkret wird
er aber nicht wir müssen deutsche es der
bericht des weltklimarates gekommen
auch bei der klimapolitik das ziel die
erderwärmung so niedrig wie möglich zu
halten
deutlich unter zwei grad besser 1,5 grad
weiter auf allen ebenen arbeiten das ist
eine aufgabe die über den tag hinaus
geht die grünen sehen alle ihre
befürchtungen bestätigt und werfen der
regierung große versäumnisse vor
fünf jahre hat diese bundesregierung
vertrödelt hat eben nicht die windräder
gebaut die wir brauchen
und jetzt gibt es keine ausreden mehr
wir wissen jetzt ins handeln beim
klimaschutz einzig die afg glaubt nicht
an den menschengemachten klimawandel
wir wissen alle dass das was geplant
wird für deutschland am klimawandel
nichts ändern wird es wird nur
arbeitsplätze und wohlstand kosten der
dramatische bericht des weltklimarates
dürfte dem bisher recht farblosen
wahlkampf in deutschland neuen
treibstoff geben und bei mir ist jetzt
der leiter der zdf umwelt redaktion
volker angres schönen guten abend
volker sie beobachten die klimakrise ja
wirklich seit jahrzehnten und selbst sie
finden den bericht erstatten
es ist tatsächlich für mich der
dramatische bericht den ich bis jetzt
auf dem schreibtisch gehabt habe weil
der weltklimarat ganz klar gesagt hat
das menschliche handeln ist die ursache
und er hat auch ganz klar gesagt im
günstigsten fall die beste prognose ist
es geht so weiter wie wir es im moment
erleben das ist der günstigste fall
das waren dieser klarheit auch noch
nicht da und wenn es aber weiter warm
werden sollte bis zu drei grad und mehr
im globalen mittel
das würde bedeuten dass viele teile
dieser erde nicht mehr bewohnbar sind
und das heißt unter anderem jede menge
neue flüchtlingsströme die auch nach
mitteleuropa auch nach deutschland
kommen werden
dann ist jetzt die grosse frage wie man
das auf hält die erderwärmung
un-generalsekretär botanisch sagt dieser
bericht muss die totenglocke für kohle
und fossile treibstoffe leuten wie kann
man das ruder noch rumreißen der
klimakrise ja der verzicht auf fossile
energieträger das ist schnell gesagt
aber leider nicht so schnell gemacht es
gibt ja viele länder die sind nach wie
vor abhängig von kohle zum beispiel
indien südafrika die haben kohlevorräte
für 10.000 jahre und mehr
natürlich muss es irgendwann in richtung
energie erneuerbare energien gehen aber
die wenn die infrastruktur in diesen
ländern dafür überhaupt nicht da ist
muss man glaube ich auch darüber reden
ob es nicht sinn macht modernste
kohlekraftwerke dorthin zu bringen
ein neues könnte drei bis vier alte
ersetzen das bringt co2 natürlich nicht
auf null
aber es kann eine sehr clevere
zwischenlösung sein weil es nämlich
relativ schnell geht und dann muss man
natürlich die schwerindustrie ins visier
nehmen die haupt emittenten das ist die
stahlindustrie aluminium das ist die
weltweite zementindustrie der
weltklimarat warnt das an dass man nicht
klein klein machen soll wir brauchen ein
weltweites internationales programm um
genau mit diesen haupt emittenten
umzugehen grüner wasserstoff ist da das
stichwort
da müssen wir hinkommen vorgang ist
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
sie wollen noch mehr erfahren zum
weltklima bericht dann schauen sie in
unsere zdf heute app dort können sie die
wichtigsten punkte noch einmal nachlesen
oder sehen was der weltklimarat genau
ist und welche aufgaben er hat ganz
konkret spüren viele menschen in süd
europa gerade die folgen der klimakrise
und des extremen wetters einige brände
konnten in der türkei in italien und in
griechenland zwar gelöscht werden
aber mehrere verheerende feuer lodern
weiter vor allem auf der griechischen
insel euböa ist die lage immer noch
dramatisch volker chat berichtet
mit dürren ästen schlagen die menschen
verzweifelt auf die feier ein
in vielen dörfern im norden der insel
warten sie bisher umsonst auf
professionelle hilfe beim löschen
überall wo sorrenti dem kleinen
küstenort kam das feuer bedrohlich nahe
die frankfurterin mary die zu rostock
betreibt hier im sommer ein kleines
hotel
ihre familie hat bange stunden hinter
sich die ganze nacht sie glaubt wie
viele auf dass die regierung die insel
geopfert hat und mit geballter feuerwehr
kraft zuerst die hauptstadt athen zu
retten wir waren allein gelassen nicht
nur im dorf auf der insel überall
rauchte das atmen schwer macht und das
24 stunden am tag das zeitraffer video
zeigt die orangerote glocke über der
insel selbst aus dem all kann man den
riesigen rauch gegenüber übersehen
die internationale hilfe ist angelaufen
auch 170 katastrophenschützer aus hessen
sind heute in richtung griechenland auf
und dafür ist für uns annette hilsenbeck
annette wo die voll gelöscht sind sieht
man alles ist verbrannt alles ist
zerstört wie soll das jetzt laufen mit
dem aufräumen der schäden wie soll es
weitergehen für die menschen vor ort er
zunächst mal so dass noch helfer kommen
also heute gerade mit der fähre wieder
eine große gruppe angekommen
die sollen helfen auf diesen
abgebrannten flächen die schwelbrände
unter kontrolle zu halten dass es also
jetzt nicht noch schlimmer wird
die bewohner kommen allmählich jetzt
auch zurück und stellen fest dass bis zu
1000 häuser verbrannt sind
und das ist natürlich in ein
riesenschreck der griechische
premierminister hat schon verkündet dass
besitzer von häusern eine entschädigung
dafür bekommen und zudem weder
erosionsschutz aufbauen wenn ihnen
herbst es regnet dass es nicht zu noch
größeren schäden durch überschwemmungen
kommt und die wälder sollen wieder
aufgeforstet werden denn diese wälder
von denen lebten die menschen hier haben
dort harz oder hc gewonnen um wein oder
farben zu produzieren und deswegen
müssen die wieder aufgeforstet werden
bis die aber wieder nutzbar werden ist
es dauert es wieder 30 bis 40 jahren
vielen dank annette hilsenbeck in
griechenland der kampf gegen die
erderwärmung ist für die grünen ihr das
thema stellt sich die frage ob sie am
ende bei der bundestagswahl von der
klimadiskussion profitieren werden
in den letzten wochen stand sich die
partei unter anderem durch mehrere
fehler der kanzlerkandidat in bernburg
vor allem selbst im weg heute nun sind
die grünen in die heiße phase des
wahlkampfs gestartet in hildesheim
patrick wiedemeyer sie haben noch genau
sieben wochen zeit bis zur
bundestagswahl zeit um für vertrauen zu
werben den holprigen wahlkampf der
letzten wochen die fehler der
kanzlerkandidatin vergessen zu lassen
das interesse der hildesheimer ist groß
einige sind aber verunsichert ich glaube
nicht dass sich die grünen
und warum weiß es noch nicht weil
annalena baerbock ein bisschen vertrauen
verspielt hat klar hat sie fehler
gemacht aber ich finde so gut wie sie zu
ihren fehlern steht und versucht jetzt
das beste für deutschland zu erzielen
die grünen sie kämpfen für eine freie
vielfältige und moderne gesellschaft
sowie für soziale gerechtigkeit nicht
länger abwarten dürfe man beim
klimaschutz so der grüne
parteivorsitzende habe kein problem
werden wir in den nächsten zwei dekaden
lösen müssen
und das heißt die erderwärmung so
einzubremsen dass wir als gesellschaft
ein leben in freiheit und würde und dem
schutz unseres lebens den hoffnung für
unsere kinder bewahren und verteidigen
reden wir um lösungen und nicht mehr um
verzagtheit weitere themen bei denen
dringend gehandelt werden müsse
digitalisierung und bildung die schulen
kitas das sind die orte um die wir uns
jetzt gemeinsam kümmern müssen um unsere
kinder die alles gegeben haben im
letzten jahr und jetzt müssen wir als
erwachsene alles geben ab morgen gehen
die beiden spitzenkandidaten auf
wahlkampftour durch deutschland mehr als
90 ortstermine sind bis ende september
geplant was für die grünen das klima
thema ist ist für die linken die soziale
gerechtigkeit umverteilen will die
partei durch ihr steuerkonzept das sie
heute vorgestellt hat
aber zurzeit kann sich die linke nicht
mal vollkommen sicher seien wieder in
den bundestag einzuziehen
im zdf politbarometer kommt sie auf 7
prozent der stimmen
ines trams berichtet einen starken
sozialstaat will die linkspartei ihre
steuerpläne würden den möglich machen
sagt spitzenkandidat dietmar bartsch
geringverdiener und mittelschicht sollen
entlastet reiche belastet werden wir
haben in unserem land ein großes problem
bei dem thema leistungsgerechtigkeit die
mehrheit verdient zu wenig und zahlt zu
viel
eine radikale steuerreform will die
linke den grundfreibetrag will sie auf
14.400 euro anheben der
spitzensteuersatz soll von 42 auf 53
prozent
jedoch erst ab einem einkommen von
76.000 euro die vermögensteuer soll
wieder eingeführt werden
an privaten reichtum will die linke ran
die mehreinnahmen dann in infrastruktur
und sozialstaat investieren der
theoretische koalitionspartner spd will
auch einen höheren spitzensteuersatz
ihr kandidat deutet aber an die pläne
der linkspartei hält er für zu radikalen
sozialdemokrat partei hat dann
zuversichtliches und sehr pragmatisches
programm entwickelt das ist mir auch
wichtig um die finanziellen folgen der
pandemie zu bewältigen schlägt die linke
eine vermögensabgabe vor
die wohlhabende mit mehr als zwei
millionen euro zahlen sollen
kontraproduktiv meint dass die cdu mit
den plänen der steuerplänen der linken
der grünen und der spd werden wir
schiffbruch erleiden wir wollen dass wir
wirtschaftlich stark bleiben dass wir
neuen wohlstand schaffen und dazu
braucht es entlastungen nicht belastung
spitzenkandidat bartsch hat die
steuerpläne der linkspartei vorgelegt
maximalforderungen es ist wahlkampf in
sachsen anhalt haben sich cdu spd und
fdp auf eine koalition geeinigt wegen
der parteifarben deutschland koalition
genannt
zwar seien die verhandlung an einigen
stellen schwierig gewesen hieß es heute
in magdeburg
jetzt sei man aber extrem optimistisch
bei cdu und spd müssen noch die
mitglieder zustimmen
bei der fdp ein parteitag im september
könnte dann ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff wiedergewählt werden
morgen beraten bund und länder darüber
wie es weitergehen soll in der korona
politik und eines zeichnet sich schon ab
cdu und spd wollen die kostenlosen
bürger tests beenden
jedenfalls für alle die sie auch impfen
lassen könnten blicken wir nun auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 1183 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden
336 mehr als vor einer woche zwei
menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kobe 19 innerhalb eines tages die sieben
tage incidents klettert auf 23,1
im düsseldorfer landtag ist mit einer
schweigeminute der fast 190 menschen
gedacht worden die beim hochwasser in
nordrhein westfalen und rheinland pfalz
ums leben gekommen sind
anschließend sagte ministerpräsident
lasche die hinterbliebenen und
geschädigten könnten auf die solidarität
aller zählen die schäden allein in nrw
liegen bei 13 milliarden euro
bund und länder planen eine food
hilfefonds offenbar über 30 milliarden
euro
nach belarus wo es vor einem jahr
richtig losging mit den massenprotesten
gegen den autoritär regierenden
präsidenten lukaschenko der auslöser er
hatte seine wiederwahl gefälscht die
proteste ließ lukaschenko niederschlagen
inzwischen sind die führenden köpfe
entweder verhaftet
eingeschüchtert oder ins ausland
geflüchtet und sogar außerhalb von
belarus lässt lukaschenko seine kritiker
innen verfolgen etwa dem blogger bruders
dessen flugzeug er unter einem vorwand
zur landung zwar für becker und axel
sturm berichten
alexander da darf er jetzt seine familie
eingepackt und ist mit ihr in die
ukraine geflogen
hier in kiew erzählt er was ihm
widerfahren sei nachdem er verhaftet
wurde weil er an anti lukaschenko demos
teilgenommen hatte so guckt mal hat mich
eingeschüchtert geschlagen sie haben mir
gedroht mich zu vergewaltigen
am jahrestag der wahl lässt lukaschenko
platz nehmen lädt ein zum großen
gespräch mit dem präsidenten verurteilt
die sanktionen des westens verbittet
sich kritik und sagt mutter da wir haben
die vorbereitungen auf die wahl damals
und die wahl selbst unter transparenten
und demokratischen bedingungen
durchgeführt sie aber andere haben dazu
aufgerufen die regierung anzugreifen
zehntausende waren im sommer 2020 auf
der straße es war der 10.000 fache ruf
nach wandel
dann aber kamen die prügel trupps das
exil der opposition deren galionsfigur
appelliert heute aus vilnius an die welt
es ist unmöglich mit diesem präsidenten
zu verhandeln er ist zu unrecht im amt
und seine macht stützt sich nur auf
gewalt die kritik aus dem ausland
verhallt das war ein angriffslustiger
ein selbstbewusster alexander
lukaschenko den wir da heute auf der
pressekonferenz erlebt haben er teilte
aus gegen die usa gegen die europäische
union gegen den westen im allgemeinen
die partnerschaft mit seinem wie er sagt
guten freund wladimir putin
die scheint ihm zu reichen zurück nach
deutschland wo es heute morgen an der a5
beinahe zu einer katastrophe gekommen
wäre
ein auto war aus ungeklärter ursache in
eine raststätten tankstelle gerast
der fahrer starb die anlage geriet
sofort in brand
über stunden kämpfte die feuerwehr gegen
die flammen die auf 5 war bei darmstadt
teilt zeitweise gesperrt schlimmeres
verhinderte ein angestellter der
tankstelle
er betätigte die notverriegelung so
entzündete sich nur in einer zapfsäule
das umziehen
und er kommt zum sport aber die letzten
deutschen olympioniken sind zurück die
sind heute nachmittag in frankfurt
gelandet und auch wenn die
medaillenausbeute nicht den selbst
gesteckten erwartungen entsprach es war
ein fröhlicher empfang und es wurde
richtig gefeiert
team germany ist zurück im gepäck
medaillen
zusammen mit jubel und viel fröhlichkeit
ja hallo ich hatte eine traumhafte zeit
in tokio für mich haben sich viele
träume erfüllt ich hoffe auf viele
andere
ich wünsche euch gleich viel spaß auf
dem römer in frankfurt mehr kommen
konnte kam zur stolzen präsentation der
medaillen noch immer auf wolke sieben
ich bin so happy so rische richtige wohl
auch jetzt mit allen wieder hier
zusammen zu sein
richtig cool trotz corona waren es
gefühlt richtige olympische spiele
es war von vorne bis hinten ein
aus meiner sicht top gelungenes event 37
medaillen für das deutsche team fünf
weniger als in rio an diesem tag aber
zählt weniger die bilanz als die freude
peinlicher patzer gestern im dfb pokal
beim wolfsburger 3 zu einzigen münster
der vfl bringt in der verlängerung einen
neuen spieler
das problem das war die sechste
auswechslung erlaubt sind aber nur fünf
münster deshalb heute einspruch gegen
die wertung des spiels eingelegt die 100
dritte minute gestern in münster
wolfsburgs neuer trainer mark van bommel
schickt bei seiner pflichtspiel-premiere
den sechs neuen spieler aufs feld ein
regelverstoß der in dem moment aber
weder von der wolfsburger bank noch vom
schiedsrichtergespann als solcher
registriert wird
der vfl hat zuvor nämlich schon fünf mal
gewechselt kurz nach dem sechsten dem
irregulären tausch erzielt wort will
horst den 2 1-führungstreffer mit dem
unzulässigen wechsel hat unser gast das
spiel zu unseren ungunsten entscheidend
beeinflusst nun stehen wir in der
verantwortung denen gegenüber die diesen
klub der auch vor großen
wirtschaftlichen herausforderungen steht
unterstützen und ihm die treue halten
das dfb sportgericht hat nun das wort
nicht wenige vermuten dass es die partie
nachträglich zu gunsten des
viertligisten wertet das war es auch
schon von sport dankeschön hat bislang
waren sonne und wärme in diesem august
ja eher fehlanzeige
das ändert sich in dieser woche mehr hat
zugleich von katja horneffer das heute
journal sehen sie um 21 45 mit claus
kleber
wir sagen auf wiedersehen machen wir es
gut
[Musik]
genau diese woche wird es sommerlich
heute allerdings zogen noch einige
schauer und gewitter vor allen dingen
über den westen und den norden
deutschlands sonst aber gab es schon
häufig sonnenschein wie in sachsen oder
auch in süddeutschland
dazu stiegen die temperaturen auf 21 bis
26 grad
heute nacht wird es vor allen dingen in
der oberpfalz recht kühl mit nur neun
grad die mildesten temperaturen finden
wie an der nordsee mit 15 grad
dazu gibt es zum teil klaren
sternenhimmel wie zum beispiel rund um
berlin aber auch am main
südlich der donau oder auch am bodensee
am anfang der nacht gibt es noch einige
regenschauer in norddeutschland und in
der zweiten nachthälfte entwickeln sich
hier von west neue gewitter und
regenschauer und gewitter weiten sich
morgen über norddeutschland dann über
tag mehr und mehr aus zwischendurch
zeigt sich bei einem recht kräftigen
wind aus südwestlichen richtungen auch
mal die sonne
südlich von main und mosel sehen sie
dagegen häufiger die sonne und das bei
westwind dort wird auch schon sommerlich
warm mit 25 bis 28 grad das gilt auch in
sachsen sonst bleiben die temperaturen
noch etwas verhalten bei 19 bis 24 grad
aber in den nächsten tagen wird es von
tag zu tag wärmer der freundlichste tag
wird wohl der donnerstag schön ab noch